we only know two species on earth in
which males live in groups
often with their relatives and go out on
raids to kill members of neighboring
communities and those were chimpanzees
and humans
[Music]
hello everyone
i'm very pleased to have today as a
guest on my
youtube channel and podcast
dr richard rangham of harvard university
he's an anthropologist and primatologist
and not only an anthropologist and
primatologist but
one of the top
certainly one of the top people in his
field
i ran across dr rangham's work back in
1996
he wrote a book with dale peterson
demonic males very provocatively titled
a study of aggression in
primates including human beings and an
analysis as well of sex differences and
i learned an awful lot from that book
and
since then he's published two others
catching fire how cooking made us human
uh
also
not a title that you would expect
because it's not as if people
popularly think about cooking as
something that made us human so that's
was very interesting it's a great book
and then more recently the goodness
paradox the strange relationship between
virtue and violence and human evolution
which was published in 2019
dr
rangham
began his career with jane goodall
studying chimpanzees in gombe stream
national park in tanzania tanzania
and began an association there with
diane fosse another stellar
primatologist who worked primarily with
gorillas he was then a professor at the
university of michigan
and finally ruth moore professor of
biological anthropology at harvard where
he is now
he's also a macarthur fellow fellow a
macarthur fellow which makes him a
recipient of the prestigious prize
popularly known as the genius grant and
so
we're going to talk today about
human evolution primate evolution
aggression the use of fire and all those
things and
so welcome dr rangham thank you very
much for agreeing to talk with me today
oh great to be here great to meet you
yeah thank you thank you so i i didn't
know i'm or perhaps i had forgotten till
i looked into you again this week that
you
more or less began your career with jane
goodall and that's pretty interesting so
do you want to walk us through your how
did your career develop how did you
develop an interest in primatology and
anthropology and maybe you could also
define those fields for everyone
i love being in the wild i love being in
nature
as a kid i liked bird watching
and that took me to more and more remote
places
by the time i was
17 i spent nine months in zambia in a
national park in which
uh it was called kafui national park it
had
something like 20 people living in it
and together with its
border areas it was slightly larger than
switzerland so it was a wonderful
opportunity to really get a sense of
what it's like to live in the wild
and i went to
oxford university to read zoology as an
undergraduate
and
after that i wrote to jane goodall and
said
is there any chance of being able to
work with her
and they the reason was that i was just
fascinated by
animals that could serve as some kind of
entry into thinking about
the way in which our ancestors uh had
uh adapted their behavior
to their own problems of of life in the
wild
so i've got two questions that stem from
that so what in the world were you doing
living in that park when you were 17 and
how did you manage that and how did that
come about and then the next question is
why were you convinced or are you
convinced now that the study of
non-human animals
is a
a useful means of shedding light on
human behavior
two very different questions um
so
i i told you i just loved the wild and
um
i'd been on on some expeditions uh to
more remote parts of britain uh in my
adolescence
but um
i saw the opportunity to uh
to do more and i wrote i don't know a
hundred letters uh to anyone whose
address i could find
uh saying could i become a research
assistant
joining you in your field studies
and a guy called john hanks who ended up
as a the chief conservation scientist
for the world wildlife fund in south
africa
was doing studies of elephants and other
things in zambia and he took me on
i was paid a shilling a day
and i just had the most incredible time
so what were your living conditions like
in that in in that particular
at that particular time well they were
very civilized i mean you know i had a a
regular little cabin
uh in a in a small
sort of camp that was ultimately
destined to become a tourist venue uh it
wasn't really at that stage it was you
know remote area you had to drive a
couple hundred miles to to get there
um but uh of course we did go camping
and so that was a major thrill uh you
know going camping in an area that
was full of um of really wild animals
and no opportunity to
uh
to to call for help as it were you know
you're you're really living on your own
so uh if you ran into wild animals uh
you had to know what to do
and in my first few
weeks there i went for a walk uh on an
in an advisable area and found myself
catching up on a on a rhino
um
and um
was only stopped from
from uh
bumping into it uh in
thick vegetation
uh by the arrival of um
well
i was lost and uh people were
shooting rifles to uh
to tell me where to go and um so you
know this is just a little adventure uh
for a
uh for a 17 year old
learning about
self-sufficiency
in the wild
and you mentioned were you studying
elephants at that point uh i was
participating i wasn't studying anything
myself but right right
and yes so i mean this is very dramatic
stuff because
um we were trying out a new drug which
has since become a standard drug for
immobilizing animals mammals in the wild
um immobile on it is now called but at
that time the delivery systems were poor
and the doses were unknown so we would
walk up to elephants
and
john would fire a crossbow dart into the
elephant
and would then hope that the elephant
would fall asleep so that we could uh
take measurements uh mark it uh
extract parasites and so on
and
the amusing thing in retrospect about
this is that when an elephant falls
asleep
it stands uh absolutely solid it doesn't
necessarily fall over you know it's like
a table got four strong legs
and so then the question is is it asleep
it seems like an important question yeah
well exactly
so instead of all of us swarming up to
it
uh one person and i'm very happy to say
that it wasn't me i was deputed to go up
and pull its tail
and and since you know you didn't know
whether or not this is a
sleep or awake
i think this is very brave of john to do
this who who took that upon himself
and
so then it turned out that he always got
it right it was asleep and then we what
we had to do was to get the elephant
onto its side
and this involved uh four of us getting
onto one side of it and pushing as hard
as we could
but this only effected a sway
so
the elephant would totter over as it
were to the right side if we were
pushing on the left and then it would
sway back towards us so we had to run
backwards and then catch it again as it
swayed
further forwards and so on yeah i mean
you can see what a sort of thrill all
this was for a young
aspiring naturalist it it sounds like a
study that would be very difficult to
get through a research ethics committee
yes and
rightly actually because um
in the previous years the person in my
position had been killed by elephants
uh you know so to there were serious
aspects uh to this and and we did have
to you know take what precautions we
could certainly right yeah well i wasn't
necessarily saying that favorably i mean
to to gain knowledge requires a certain
degree of risk and i suspect that's
particularly true when you're out in the
wild observing wild animals that's not
something you can make 100 safe i mean
obviously you don't want to be foolhardy
but
and there is the thrill of of of the
adventure that goes along with that
that's a necessary part of it i think
although by the way when um
a woman called nancy howell had her son
killed um
in um
while she was doing field work in south
africa or i think it might even botswana
she did an analysis of deaths among
anthropologists doing field work and
found that the major source of death was
car accidents
right right
you know the roads are bad
right yes well in car accidents are a
major killer everywhere so maybe that's
a good rule of thumb for danger if it's
safer if it's no more dangerous than
driving a car which is something almost
everyone accepts maybe that's safe
enough so
okay so you got accustomed to this and
you found that you liked it you went
back to oxford and studied zoology
and then you and then you wrote to jane
goodall i've got that
yes timeline correct this was the late
1960s that i was studying zoology and um
there were two writers whose
work had sort of really impinged on the
public imagination at that time in
relationship to human evolution there
was robert audrey
a playwright who wrote a book called
african genesis another called
territorial imperative
in which uh he produced some bold
sweeping ideas about how uh human
competitiveness and conflict had arisen
from um our time when our ancestors were
in africa
and there was desmond morris who wrote a
book called naked ape
uh in which he emphasized in particular
the uh the sexual side of of human
evolution
and what those books did for me was to
say that there was a world out there
waiting to be explored of
a really understanding in a way that had
not been attempted before
where humans come from in terms of our
behavior
simultaneously
this was a time when
the discovery of the social structure of
all sorts of large mammals
was taking giant leaps forward
you know the main study that i was doing
uh with john hanks in
1967 in zambia was a study of the
behavioral ecology
of an antelope called water bug
it's a very widespread antelope
behavioral ecology means understanding
the social behavior in relationship to
all the environmental pressures
this was the first such study done on
waterbug no particular surprise because
it
many of the first studies were being
done at that time on any animal animals
uh on on lions and gorillas and
and many different things
so there was a sense of of impending
discovery and what happened even in the
late 60s but particularly in the early
70s was the discovery of
a lot of difference in the different
species even quite closely related
species might have not just differences
in group size and flexibility but
differences in their social
relationships in what at first seemed
totally mysterious ways you know one
species would have
a society in which females all
lived in the same group as that they
were born in
would never leave and males would come
in from outside
around adolescence
other species the opposite would happen
some species would have females that
readily mated every different male in
the group
others would have
a society in which females would only
mate with one male
all sorts of
fascinating
differences were emerging
and
hints were coming through about how you
could explain these
so
this was a
a very exciting moment because
when you combine it with the opportunity
to think about humans
then
we could get you know a long way beyond
the kind of um
very
naive uh political
science interpretations of human
behavior we could really embed it in the
environment in which humans had
evolved so that's a that's a tricky
issue you know because well one of the
things your work highlights and this has
been the case with other primatologists
particularly more recently is that
because you just mentioned that
species that are even very closely
related can have radical differences in
their fundamental behaviors and you
highlight the differences for example
between bonobos
and chimpanzees which are very closely
related and so then you ask yourself
well if barnables and chimpanzees can be
so biologically similar structurally
similar let's say but so behaviorally
different how is it that you
decide what's reasonably generalized to
the human case
and and why should you believe that
anything could be given right because
there's there's there's similarities and
differences between
all of the apes and so
how do you
prioritize the similarities versus the
differences and how do you decide when
when you can draw conclusions that are
more universal rather than local to that
particular species
yeah i mean
this is the kind of stuff that we
grapple with all the time of course um
and
i i think it's quite a long story
working out
what we can say about humans in
relationship to
uh call it the other apes or or the
great apes you know so we have
a
a very strange position uh as humans uh
it used to be thought when i started for
instance uh in the 1970s uh it was
fascinating to go and study chimpanzees
but they were just one species of great
ape among the other uh main three
gorillas bonobos and orangutans
that all seemed
so roughly equally important for
understanding human evolution there was
the apes and there was humans
an enormous
shock happened in 1984.
in 1984 two
ornithologists at yale
uh calcone and powell
published a paper in which
they used techniques that they'd been
applying to the study of the evolution
of birds
to
the apes and humans and this technique
was to
assess the degree of similarity of dna
so they'd worked out this dna and
kneeling system and they applied it to
apes and humans
and they claimed
that chimpanzees and bonobos were the
most closely related species
and then chimpanzees bonobos and humans
were more closely related to each other
than any of them were to gorillas
so that kind of put us in the in the
chimp category now let me ask you just
there
i want to ask you a question about that
dna technique now if i remember
correctly
the way that was done to begin with was
to
to take dna from separate species and to
heat it so that the the it's split
apart and then to have the dna from the
different species join together
and then to assess how tightly bonded
the
dna
was to the to the between species and
the the hypothesis was the more tightly
bonded it was so the harder it was to
pull apart once it re grouped the more
closely related the species was that was
the first way of doing dna similarity
analysis that's been superseded but was
that the 1984 work
very good yes absolutely
and um
the the technique was a little crude
um
unzip things and zip them together and
see how tough they are to pull apart
um and that crudeness meant that people
could challenge the results
and it took
maybe a decade for people to become you
know the the profession as a whole to
become really convinced at these
extraordinary results and the reason
they seemed so extraordinary was because
if you take the difference between a
chimpanzee and a gorilla
they look as if they're very closely
related they look so closely related
because if you just imagine allowing a
chimpanzee to just keep on growing it
basically turns into a gorilla
and many of the differences between
gorillas and chimps can be understood
just in terms of body size gorillas
being bigger than chimps
so when the argument is made that uh or
actually you know that's where normal
argument i mean just absolutely clear
right now
that uh
that chimpanzees and humans are more
closely related to each other than
either is to a gorilla
what that means is that the common
ancestor of chimps and humans
is very likely in the mold of the
chimpanzee gorilla
either
either they're the same very similar
kind of animal which if it was very
large would be like a gorilla if it was
very small it would be like a
chimpanzee
um
either that or there's been a fantastic
degree of evolutionary convergence
between some uh mysterious ancestor
which would become more guerrilla-like
and become more chimp-like but no one
thinks that that is the case right so so
the idea is that and this is this is
what how long ago did gorillas split
from chimps hypothetically is that like
10 million years ago
10 million so so the common ancestor of
chimps and gorillas and the chimps in
this discussion include us
roughly speaking so that's 10 million
years and then seven million years ago
we split from chimps and the barnabas
and the and the chimps split two million
something like that or one or two
million years ago yes right so
maybe more like one nowadays they we're
still getting a uh
increasingly confident uh assessment of
that but anyway much more recently not
long after
we had left the chimpanzee bonobo line
right and we we might just also throw
out the
uh finding i suppose the hypothesis that
homo sapiens sapiens that's us
that we're about 300 000 years old in
our current configuration something like
that yes and in between uh we got the
genus homo
so the genus to which we belong um and
that emerged about two million years ago
so so you you've got the common ancestor
with chimps six or seven million years
ago
and then uh between then and two million
years ago
we had these uh animals that are rather
like chimpanzees standing upright
australopithecines
and they gave rise to our genus homo
about two million years ago and ever
since then
our ancestors have basically looked like
us
i basically in the sense that
you could take the earliest homo homo
true homo homo erectus and they could
walk into a clothing store on main
street and pick clothes off the peg
and they wouldn't they'd fit reasonably
well they'd be you know they need the
big size
heavily muscled but nevertheless
we can we can estimate the the the the
difference the that
we can estimate when we when these
different species split from one another
by looking at the
degree of genetic difference and
inferring the split from
such things as divergent mutations
because we know that mutations occur at
a fairly standard rate is that is that
and then there's obviously fossil dating
but
what what other techniques are used to
estimate the divergent states
yeah the more recent times obviously
we've got the fossils
so you know we have a very good fossil
record uh back to uh more than two
million years ago
and and we can be very confident that
our ancestors were indeed uh homo rectus
uh which as i say i mean was the first
thing that was fully bipedal um
in the human style
going back to two million years ago and
then uh then we got a pretty good record
but obviously the older you go the more
broken it is
but of the australopithecines
and uh
by the time we get to uh three four
million years ago it's getting
increasingly broken but nevertheless
there's half a dozen different species
and more that have been recognized in
the african
habitats
and
and then by the time you're asking the
question about when it was that you have
chimpanzees
and humans
as a common ancestor with a common
ancestor there you do have to rely on
genetic data as you say
the rate at which
mutations accumulate
because we do not have any good fossil
evidence for that
animal
and the reason for that is partly just
as getting old
and also probably because it would have
left lived in a forest and forests don't
um preserve bones well you know they
tend to be too acid and the bones just
decay very quickly
but i bet eventually someone will find a
pretty good
you know something close to the the
chimpanzee human common ancestor
so 10 million years okay so let's go
back to the biography now you you you
came out of africa you studied zoology
you wrote to jane goodall and you told
her about your experiences in africa so
she knew that you could probably handle
it why and and by that time you had an
undergraduate degree i did that's right
so you started working with her in
where in in tanzania tanzania tanzania
yeah in 1970 and so what was that like
and what what was what was it like to
work for her and what did what were you
what were you doing during that period
of time
for my first year i was a research
assistant to her
i was just learning the job
and i i would say that within about 20
minutes of seeing my first chimpanzee in
the wild i recognized that there was a
mind in that animal that was different
from that of a water bug
uh you know this is not just an antelope
and it's difficult to say exactly what's
going on you know but but there's
something about the use of eyes and
something about uh
you know the way that they're evidently
concocting
strategies
that very rapidly tells you
that you're dealing with an animal that
is
uh like other animals but also is
cognitively you know quite sophisticated
and of course that makes it incredibly
interesting now this is 1970 i said long
before i i had any kind of concept that
we were looking at a good model of the
human ancestor
so this is just you know another ape
but here's what was so
amazing you know i happened to arrive
there at a time when some very
fundamental discoveries uh were were
being made
jane goodall had already
discovered that
uh chimpanzees
had very strong relationships among
males very very brotherly uh very
fraternal relationships
uh somewhat
recalling the kind of thing that you can
see in
i don't know um
fraternities in
uh
you know contemporary humans
she discovered that uh amazingly
they would go hunting
and
would
kill
antelope
pigs
baboons other monkeys
and eat them she discovered that they
would shed they valued meat they valued
meat they valued meat to eat
uh
but they would also share it a little
bit
uh and uh by the time you're racking up
these male bondings the meat eating
the
meat sharing this is looking
extraordinarily human-like no other
animal does these things
and did they share for sexual favors the
chimps did she discover that that the
males would give me to the females
i can't remember if i'm remembering that
correctly
well
you may indeed remember what you read
some colleagues and i have published a
paper saying we don't believe that for a
minute
uh that it does not look to us as though
any of the evidence that has been
brought forward in favor of the idea
that chimpanzees that male chimpanzees
will give meat to females in order to
get them to mate
none of that evidence is good
right that's pretty sophisticated
behavior it would imply some knowledge
of trait like of trading with with
future gain in mind it would seem to me
well i don't think the problem of
sophistication
is difficult
i think chimpanzees could easily handle
that based on on other kinds of
interactions they have
the thing is that
among chimps
sexual system is very different from
others and females really really want to
mate other males as much as possible
i have seen female chimpanzee go into a
a
a tree containing 10 males
climb to the highest ranking mail
present to him hoping he will mate her
and he turns his nose up matter
and she then goes
ranked by rank down the ranks
to the different males and finally we'll
get some juvenile male to to mate with
her
that's just symbolic of the fact that
she is desperate to get mated as much as
possible and and she she's also
with the chimps
the the females are they have an estrous
period that's not hidden
correct
uh it's
it's very visually striking that's right
uh so the
the labia uh increase under the
influence of estrogen
so that
you have quite a large swelling
and very pink
very obvious from hundreds of yards away
so males know when she has the swelling
but there is a little bit of subtlety to
this so in the first i mean she hasn't
swelling for maybe 10 days at a time
once a month during a period that she's
trying to get pregnant
and during the first week of the
swelling the males are not particularly
interested in her they appear to know as
it were that she is unlikely actually to
have ovulated at that time
they get much more interested towards
the end of the period of swelling and
that's when the big males come in the
high-ranking males and and exert
their dominance to be able to compete
for the female
but she is interested in mating
throughout this period and she can mate
sometimes 50 times a day
and the reason is very clear
the reason is that
any male who has not mated her
is dangerous to her subsequent infant
because a male
who has failed to mate
the logic is that he cannot be the
father
and if he's not
then the infant
is worthy of
being killed because
how how does he track that
let's not know
um it's it's almost certainly memory
um but we don't know for sure you know
and there are animals in which it it
happens with mechanisms other than
memory
so uh do you know the story about how it
happens in mice
no no
well there's a wonderful study of mice
in which uh
they they assess the infanticidal
tendency of males uh
by uh seeing how desperate they are to
get at infants
and what they were able to show
is that um the tendency to be
infanticidal
happens
21 days which is the length of gestation
of the mouse
um
after a mating
and the way they're able to show that
that it's an account of the number of
days is they manipulated the length of
the day
uh night cycle
so that if you had day night cycles
eight hours long and eight hours eight
hours a day and eight hours of night
then they would come in and try and
commit infanticide after
21 of those
if you extended them to
16 hours or or longer of a
day and 16 hours of night then
they would commit infanticide they would
try to come in front side 21
of those cycles later
so some animals can have just an
internal clockwork
regardless of the actual time so if they
hadn't mated 21 days earlier they would
assume that those infants aren't theirs
that's right
that's right so they do get the
inhibition
i hope i said that right uh it's in the
after 21 uh dark light cycles
that's remarkable such a
sort of mechanical system uh applies to
chimpanzees it's much more likely that
that they actually have a memory
of uh of when
and how often
and under what circumstances they made
it a particular female
so we don't know that um exactly but at
any rate
it
it certainly fits with all that we know
from other primates
that uh where there is some direct
experimental evidence about this
that
females
risk the lives of their infants if they
do not
mate with all of the males in the group
on a regular basis
and is that also is that characteristic
of the barnables as well
uh the in the in bonobos the the females
uh famously have even more sex than uh
in chimpanzees
and
no infanticide has been recorded
and so all one can say is that
if there is an infanticide threat the
females have overcome it
by successfully persuading every male
every time that he is a potential father
right right so you can't see any
exceptions to that
so well so that's a marked as you
pointed out to begin with that's a
marked difference with human behavior
all of that
no including the in
human females famously have concealed
ovulation as well which is also a
massive difference
so human males cannot tell with any
degree of certainty
when a female is most likely to be
impregnated
um and
it's that's an interesting evolutionary
divergence and that's something have you
thought about is that something that
you've that you've developed a
particular theory about or thought about
in it to any great degree is that
something we could pursue because it's a
fascinating
it is a fascinating difference yeah i
mean um
i i would say that uh
no i haven't thought about it in detail
and and i would say nobody has a really
convincing story but but the basic story
is that um with humans we have shifted
away from females mating all males in
the group uh females mate uh with one
male at a time essentially there's a
little bit of gene shopping but um but
basically females are bonded to a
particular male and and i do see the
uh the bonding as quite strongly
associated
with cooking
okay that's not an obvious connection so
i would love to hear about that well
why do you why do you why do you believe
that
if you look now at people living in open
earth societies
then what you see is
a sexual division of labor
in which
females are
cooking
food for themselves and their children
and for a male
and
they their big job in life is to uh
produce food for the male from the point
of view of their relationship with the
male
he absolutely needs
uh to rely on having a
meal when he comes back in the evening
from whatever he's been doing whether
it's been hunting or
politicking with people in a neighboring
group or or searching for enemies or
whatever
and the reason he needs it is because he
needs cooked food just like every other
human and he doesn't have time to cook
the food himself
so if his wife doesn't cook the food for
him then she's in trouble
um
what
the
the so the female uh is bonded to the
male in the sense that the male needs
her to provide food for him
uh if if she is um
sexually promiscuous
then uh for obvious reasons the the male
is upset
uh and so he will
um
punish her uh he will he will beat her
he will
maybe dispose of her
and get another female if he can
and she needs him to do the things that
he's out doing having been fed like
providing high quality protein for
example
and that's
the standard story is that that she
needs him uh to produce
meat and other
good foods
i think there's something else though
that
is critical once you get to cooking and
the reason that she needs him once you
have cooking
is that
cooking exposes the cook
to
theft
so when you cook
you need a fire
fire produces smoke everybody knows
you're cooking
from a long way away people can detect
the fact that you are cooking they can
smell the smoke they can see the smoke
just it's just a very practical thing
that means that uh for people who are
lazy people who don't want to um cook
their own food people who don't even
want to
find their own food people who who uh
maybe are are sick
a person who is cooking food
is vulnerable to having their food
stolen
and a woman
cooking the food
is particularly vulnerable to men
such as a man who is not yet got his own
wife
so bachelors are a problem for a woman
and uh and so might be the elder
children of uh other females uh um so
might be uh another another woman you
have all sorts of sources of of risk
and this is where a woman's bond to a
man is really important once uh cooking
emerges
because he can be relied on as somebody
who can protect her not necessarily from
actually being there at the time that
a bachelor appears and tries to pinch
some of the food on her fire
but because she can go to the husband
and say
that lousy rat
has taken some of my food
and
you know we're getting ahead of
ourselves in terms of thinking about the
nature of human society because the
thing i have to bring into this stage is
that
uh in all human societies you have a
collection of men
who form an alliance among themselves
so that the husband of the cook
is not just a man who can stand up for
his wife and and
threaten any bachelor who approaches her
with theft in mind
he's more than that because he can go
to the rest of the men
and say you know guys we've got a
trouble
we got some guy who is not respecting
the norms in this society
and that's a much more potent threat
than one guy standing up
for a one-on-one fight
because all of a sudden you've got the
whole society now led by those men
ready to
enforce some quite severe punishment
yeah you're you you you're starting to
explore that idea and we'll we'll go
back to that pretty deeply in your last
book on on
what you described as the
self-domestication of human beings that
that enforcement of moral norms and the
control of of
well hyper-aggressive behavior but also
behavior that's breaking rules yes so
we'll come to that but to come back to
the question of what you asked about
do male chimpanzees share food share
meat with estrus females
right uh females who who are
available to mate
one of the reasons other than just the
shortage of direct observations
that you don't expect this is because
a male does not need to produce meat to
persuade a female to mate with him in
humans that is necessary or you know
under the appropriate circumstances
but not in chips
more likely that a female would have to
pay a male to mate her
i mean not that really
needs to happen but um
anyway
this is an example to me of a behavior
that was written up quite early in the
study of chimpanzees in the 1970s
on
i think too optimistic assumption that
something that you saw that was
reminiscent of human behavior might
easily be interpreted as being
equivalent
so you know occasionally a male might
allow a an interest female to um to take
some meat and everyone leaps on it and
says hey look just like humans
as it turns out
females who are not easteros are more
likely to get meat than a female who is
easterless as it turns out when you have
females with easter with sexual
swellings then there is less hunting
going on than when those females are
absent
there's all sorts of evidence now that
you know this is not a a confident
relationship at all
so i think it's an object lesson in
the care you need for thinking about
similarities between uh humans and
um and primates and chimpanzees right
well when one of the ways you you kind
of check yourself against such things as
a scientist is that before you generate
any
theory
you know of spectacular originality you
might want to ensure that multiple lines
of
evidence suggest it and that those lines
of evidence have been drawn from
divergent and non-overlapping sources
yeah that's right exactly it check
checks you against your own projections
yeah that's right and and that that kind
of um
caution
applied particularly to one of the
additional features that was emerging
as i was joining the chimpanzee study in
the 1970s
which actually really happened while i
was there and that is the discovery of
something even more shocking than um
uh
than hunting meat sharing and tool use
the famous tool use you know all these
things that were
very similar between chimpanzees and
humans well then it turned out that
chimpanzees
were
holding territories against other
chimpanzees and would sometimes
go to the territorial boundaries look
for opportunities to stalk and hunt
and kill
members of neighboring groups and those
members of neighboring groups would be
almost entirely adult males
so now we had for the first time
something that looked like
a primitive kind of war
yes and that the importance of that can
hardly be overstated
i mean when i first read that it just
shocked me to the core because i thought
well
you know if you're an optimist in some
sense you might assume that the human
proclivity for war is a consequence of
let's say maladaptive socialization or
something like that that could
hypothetically be easily controlled but
to see
an analog of that so striking in
chimpanzees
was
well it was an indication of just
exactly how deep that proclivity is that
that proclivity to dehumanize let's say
so to speak out group members
and to
treat them as prey
yeah it's an indication but but uh you
know as my uh great advisor robert hind
the
animal behaviorist
endlessly emphasized to me you know
you've got to be really really cautious
about thinking
how to understand
what this chimpanzee behavior means for
for humans
and uh and i think you know we have been
as a a profession uh pretty cautious
about it
but um
yeah so one of the first things that
happened was people said well it's very
likely that uh this pattern of
chimpanzees killing members of
neighboring groups males in neighboring
groups
is
something to do
with disturbance to that particular
population and it won't turn it'll turn
out not to happen in other populations
and it took uh gosh um
uh 30 years
to
develop enough confidence in what was
happening in all of the other
populations to be able to say you know
what this is a characteristic feature of
chimpanzees and by the time
we
had those data coming in we could also
say
what it was associated with
and the answer is
it was associated with high population
density and
large numbers of males in the aggressive
community
so you get lots of males together
and they will look for opportunities to
kill members of neighboring groups
and what what is it not associated with
uh it's not associated with uh measures
of human disturbance
um whether or not the forest had been
subject to a bit of logging or how many
people live nearby
that sort of thing the chimpanzees don't
care about that sort of stuff they're
living their own lives and
their social dynamics are
concerned with
what's going on in their own species
lives
so why is a preponderance of males in
the attacking is that just a matter of
outnumbering the enemy or or are there
other factors at play
numbering looks the important thing yes
right because
they won't attack the chimps generally
don't attack outside their boundaries
unless they
they clearly outnumber those that they
are targeting correct and that
explanation for that
they
they
they have a rudimentary sense of number
of of or
amount something like that is it number
or amount they have a rudimentary sense
of that at least
yeah i mean yeah they're very smart and
it turns out that the
average ratio
of the number of males in an attacking
group
to the number of males in the victim
group
is eight to one
and what this comes down to is uh eight
males attacking one
you know it's not 16 males attacking two
and so in this average system when eight
males attack one uh here's what can
happen uh you each of four males grab
one limb
and then you have a helpless victim
and the remaining four can do what they
like to that victim and they do
and uh you know they can terrorize
thorax and pull his testes off and uh
twist their arms until the bones break
and uh
blood is coming out from everywhere and
so on it's a really nasty business
and you know chimpanzees are
depends on exactly what measure you like
but you know it's maybe they're three or
four times stronger than humans uh they
are immensely strong
and uh so a chimpanzee fighting for its
life
could in theory
impose immense damage on its attackers
but the chimps that attack are so smart
and and figured out exactly how to do
this that there is not a single case out
of some 50 attacks that have been
reasonably well documented of any of the
aggressors
being damaged beyond a scratch
so
they know what they're doing um and this
is the you know the imbalance of power
hypothesis that what has happened in
chimpanzee social evolution
is that
because
you have
variation in the
number of companions that individuals
have within their communities as they
walk about looking for opportunities to
eat as well as possible and find females
and all that sort of stuff
you have variation which exposes
occasional victims to occasional large
groups and just the fact of having
a lot of males in your group means that
you have
safety when it attacking
imbalance of power is enough
to induce attack
so you know for me this is um this is
classic lord acton power corrupts and
absolute power corrupts absolutely
and so what's in it for the attacking
chimps what is it that they gain
they don't gain immediate food
they don't gain immediate females you
know they don't walk back to their
communities um with
a kidnapped female or anything like that
they don't
show in the next few days uh increased
acquisition of
fruit from a tree on the boundary
nothing like that
but what they do gain
is uh increased confidence in moving in
an area that was previously more evenly
used between the two communities
oh so they decrease the probability that
they're going to be someone who's one
against eight
it's partly the safety problem like that
but um
but also
uh it gets it just gets them access to
more
resources in that area in general so you
know during the months and years to come
they're able to spend more time in such
and such a valley
where they have killed
and we now have
nice data from from two different
studies one in tanzania one in uganda uh
showing that you get a occupation of the
area where the killings have occurred
and in one case beautiful showing all of
the expected consequences for
uh the
quality of the diet
so
a
better food
increased body mass even uh known of the
um
the individuals that are able to occupy
a larger area uh reduction in the
time between births for those females
so the females are feeling better the
males are feeling better
and
even
increased
survival of the offspring in that
community as a whole
and how much killing does it take to
produce such effects i mean is is it is
the elimination of one or two
individuals from a neighboring
troop sufficient to do that like what
scale does this have to occur at before
those consequences emerged anyone know
in those two best known cases in one
case all the males in the neighboring
community were killed
i see so it was complete obliteration
of the of competitors it was initially a
small community there were only seven
males in it
and they were all killed
i i shouldn't say they were all killed i
should say they all died and in
um
four maybe five cases they were known to
be uh attacked
uh and killed
so so is that typical is the typical
behavior
to move
in those situations towards complete
elimination
it's typical
uh and it may well not be i mean you
know if you've got a very large
community
neighboring then um i could well imagine
that they they kill several and it just
means they they are able to dominate uh
an area that was previously more evenly
shared
so in the case of the ugandan
story at in gogo in kibali national park
uh you had
um
something over 20 kills that were made
in various different parts of the
boundary of the killer community
but
not enough was known about the neighbors
to be sure what proportion that meant or
that was of of the neighbours it's
unlikely that many neighboring
communities were completely eliminated
though
those those are immense communities you
know that that killer community at that
time
uh had uh
25 fully adult and and over
i think 35
adult and adolescent males
you know this is a an immense power
and they were living in an area with
just tremendous food productivity and
a number of communities that had a large
number of males but but they were
probably the biggest boss on on the
block
so you you were working with goodall
when that initial rating behavior was
documented
yes i mean i i saw some of the first
raids
um and um
it's no wonder you wrote your first book
that were inspired to do the work to
write your first book which was demonic
males i mean that must have really i
mean that that's quite a bombshell that
that discovery like goodall was if if i
remember correctly and informed him
correctly goodall was quite hesitant
about sharing those results for some
period of time i believe
is that have i got that right or was she
just being cautious or what what's the
story there well i don't think that's
right oh okay um
you know it's funny uh william boyd
wrote a book called browserville beach
which was
obviously inspired by what happened in
gombe and
in that case the protagonist the jane
goodall figure
was
very reluctant to share the results and
i think that that may have affected the
you know the popular understanding but
no jane in 1979
she published a a paper
that was describing some of these
results
and
i think she's always had a very
faithful and honest
uh approach to to presenting this she
didn't hide it
yeah well i wasn't i wasn't i was
certainly wasn't suggesting that i mean
i can imagine though that a scientist in
her position would
want uh what would you call to be damn
sure of the proposition before releasing
it on the world well fair enough yes and
and uh no i mean she's
um
i think she's been appropriately
cautious you know she described what was
seen
i think i probably did go a bit beyond
her in um
in inferring the more general tendencies
um
and so
but but you know by 20 years later
96 when i published demonic males with
dale peterson
i think it was pretty clear what was
going on and then as i said you know
another 30 years later the data were
really coming in very very solidly and i
i
i mean in some ways i
wasn't too keen on the type of demonic
males because
it's a little bit in your face
i wanted to make is that it is very
extraordinary because
we only know two species on earth or at
that stage we only knew two species on
earth in which males live in groups uh
often with their relatives and go out on
raids to kill members of neighboring
communities and those were chimpanzees
and humans
yeah well when i picked up the book i
mean i
i was very interested in the scientific
study of aggression at the time and when
i picked up the book i thought the same
thing about the title i thought but the
book itself is a very uh scholarly
examination of this proclivity and
so so so for people who are listening
who are interested it's a very very
solid book and it it isn't uh it isn't
uh
uh
it looks
let's say accessible yes well it's
accessible but it's also it's also
careful it's not sensationalistic at all
yeah
and and that's the case with all of your
work it's very serious work and so so
walk us through demonic males you've
done some of that so we're going to jump
ahead a bit because you've done a lot of
things and i want to cover a lot of it
before we close you
anything else you want to say about the
first your work with with with jane
goodall and and and that that setting
you up for for the long term study of
chimpanzees
sure
well i mean i
i actually started feeding behavior um
when i was working with chimpanzees and
i think it's a great thing to study
because
it emphasizes you know the most
important aspect of an ordinary animal's
life
uh the
just this daily search for food
you know people
when they come to film chimpanzees uh
they often are expecting to see
tool use or dramatic sexual behavior or
or something exotic uh in their first
day or two and they say this is so
boring you know they're spending
six hours a day just sitting in trees
eating
yeah well i think it was in your in the
book
uh catching fire maybe is it in that
book do you document is it is it in that
book that
gorillas that the documentation of
gorillas spending up to eight hours a
day doing nothing but chewing leaves
that's right they have to do that
because their diet is not particularly
rich and so they don't have time for
much else and with chimps as well like
it takes a lot of calories to keep a
chimp going and so there there's and
that's also perhaps
offers some insight into why it took
human culture so long to explode in the
way it does it's very difficult to get
beyond hand-to-mouth living
yeah i just think it's it's a really
helpful
um sort of embedding of of the reality
of animals lives
and it's not something necessarily comes
across when you you read about their
social behavior
but
they are spending most their time
um
strategizing about how to uh get as much
food as possible
and and i found that immensely helpful
but on the other hand
it took me
a long time before the penny dropped you
know i actually tried to
to uh to live like a chimpanzee a little
bit in the sense of of eating what
chimpanzees at you know i ate everything
chimpanzees at and i discovered very
rapidly that i got extremely hungry if i
did that
the penny finally dropped
in the 90s when i realized
that
there was a huge difference between
chimpanzee and human diets and that is
that humans cook our food and
and that you know developed a whole new
story
so but i mentioned the importance of
seeing chimpanzees feeding and spending
time thinking about their attitude to
to using their environment to maximize
the amount of food they can get
because
it's a it's a big problem for humans too
and you know this is this is nature in
the raw
how on earth do you get enough to
satisfy those endless pangs of hunger i
think you've got to think of these
animals as being hungry all the time
and it's difficult for us to get into
that mentality because we are never
hungry
we we can satisfy our food
needs all the time right so so we
underestimate how relevant that is by a
massive degree i mean your book catching
fire was struck striking to me i suppose
in almost the same way that
my encounter with the data showing that
chimpanzees went on raids i mean you you
made the claim for example that well you
think human beings have been using fire
for about two million years which is
an awful long time uh well in some sense
it's
longer than i had
longer than many suppositions and you
also make a very strong case that
our proclivity to use fire and cook has
radically altered
well our whole morphology our whole
physiology our our
intestinal system our digestive system
and that that's provided us with the
additional
calories necessary to
expend some resources on on brainpower
more resources on brainpower have i got
that right i hope i'm not doing your
booking injustice and the other
absolutely no that's all right and the
other big thing that it did is to
hugely increase the amount of time we
can spend on things other than choice
right right exactly to free it free us
up to because to do nothing long enough
to think about something other than like
immediate food food acquisition
cooking softens food
and and it softens it so much that that
we can spend just a fraction of time
chewing uh compared to any of our ape
relatives you know so if we were eating
our food raw we would be spending
probably more than six hours a day
chewing our food and as it is we spend
less than an hour a day chewing our food
so that saves us five hours a day and
gosh you know that is important it's uh
it has different importance for females
and for males
in terms of how females and males
actually spend their time now
and the irony is that females do a lot
of food preparation i mean this is
worldwide
the only exceptions to it are in
modern urban society
but um
much of the saving of chewing time is
translated into uh
females for females into gathering food
uh preparing it and cooking it for males
there's much more freedom given by
that saving of time to go off and do
high risk high gain activities like like
hunting
but also uh politicking
visiting people in the neighboring camp
chasing women in the neighboring camp
and so on
and the contribution to cultural
production artistic production like
aesthetic
production bead making all of that
that's all that exactly
that that's right i mean you know all of
a sudden you have um
a totally different attitude to time
from from other people you have some of
it
exactly right right and so so two
million years ago
so what were our ancestors like two
million years ago when they discovered
fire and how it
it you know
i'm thinking how has that come about
well one of the things that's really
interesting about fire as far as i'm
concerned is that it's it's archetypally
interesting you know if i i spend time
at my parents cottage and i used to
bring my little kids up there and you
know adults human adults will sit in a
circle and look at two things they'll
look at infants and little kids like
intently watch them non-stop as if
they're in eternally interesting they
don't habituate to that but we also
don't seem to habituate to fire
and i'm wondering if you know two
million years ago there was a
mutation that
that occurred that made someone
comp some
some ancestor absolutely unable to stay
away from fire because it was no longer
he was no longer able to habituate to it
so it was endlessly fascinating
so i don't know what you think about
that idea but no though there were
probably various kinds of
adaptations psychological um and
physiological adaptations to to being
near fire uh to being drawn to fire and
so on um but i think they would follow
the discovery of um
of being able to control it and and just
how useful it was
um exactly how that happened i don't
know i mean you know my
my personal fantasy uh goes along these
lines that um
you've got nostrolopythoscene um
so that's you know like a chimpanzee
standing upright it's uh just got a big
jaw and eating raw foods
big teeth
it's um
by the size of a chimpanzee
and uh
it's clear that there was increasing
evidence in the fossil record
of um
of meat eating
and
how that comes about uh who knows
but uh but if they're eating more meat
then
meat is not that easy to eat if it's raw
but it's a lot easier to eat if you
pound it if you if you just you know do
a steak tartare on it
and
so my fantasy is that they were eating
more meat they were using rocks to pound
the meat
sometimes sometimes they'd use wood but
when they use rocks sparks would come
out and sparks would sometimes start
little fires and so they re-repeatedly
be exposed to fires in relationship to
their activity
and
this would happen often enough that out
of this would learn they'd learn the
opportunity to
um
leave
meat
near a fire
and and taste the value
how how often are animals
edible
animals
trapped in grass fires in africa
you know people often
refer to that idea but i don't think it
happens very often at all
i i've i'm not i don't believe there's
any studies uh in which people have
actually you know documented a number
um most animals are able to escape by
either borrowing underground or running
away from the fire
um
you know it's conceivable that that that
is the way it happened that it happened
often enough that people you know
figured it out that australopithecines
figured out what was going on
you know it's all speculation as to how
fire was first controlled
but um
but i think what is
uh
clear is that once it was first
controlled it would have had huge
effects you know we know that all
animals like their food cooked compared
to like eating it raw or all that have
been tested
so
not just our domestic animals but wild
animals too all the apes for instance
prefer it cooked they just haven't
figured out how to cook it and how do
you account for that seems very strange
that that that
how is it that that could possibly be
the case like why do animals prefer
cooked food
it's because what cooking does is
essentially pre-digest food
and and animals like their food as much
digested as possible because the more of
digestion you can
have done for you then the less you have
to do it yourself and
there's a major cost right well i can
see i can see that it makes sense i just
can't see how they would have possibly
developed the taste for it or the the
odor preference or any of that uh i mean
do you you don't come
to come i mean is it is it in some sense
like partially decomposed food
you know maybe with that a little bit um
so you know softness i mean in general
animals like their food soft because uh
harder food is tougher and it's you're
gonna do more chewing and so there's a
texture issue there's a texture with you
and probably the taste um
you know
as you say a little bit of decomposition
so
if proteins have been
partly denatured
then you have more exposure to the amino
acids that have a bit of sweetness to
them uh have a bit of umami flavor
and
and all of those are indicators to even
to an ape that the food is uh relatively
uh going to be relatively easy to digest
right it's bioavailable and ready for
use
right right right but but actually no
one has uh
um the spontaneous interest in the the
odor of cooked food and that's something
would be really fun to do
but certainly a striking character right
well it's certainly a striking
characteristic of human response to
especially caramelized meat which has a
particularly distinctive and delicious
odor
yeah right
right
um so so you know this is still an early
early science you know we don't know
that much about it but what we do know
is that animals
including the great apes prefer their
food cooked even when they haven't had
any exposure to it
you know when they're naive
and that once you are eating cooked food
you are getting more calories
you're saving yourself the cost of
digestion and you're actually increasing
the amount of the food that you are able
to digest as well
so the net result uh
in experiments that uh that i my
colleagues have done i
you get uh indications of 30 50 percent
increase in the number of calories i
mean this is huge you know for right
five percent more milk out of their cows
you know they're a millionaire and now
we're talking you know some tens of
percent
right right
essential a doubling of of available
calories and and you also pointed out
not only the the caloric improvement but
the radical decrease in the amount of
time it takes to do the processing like
the chewing
right
so yes so this would be really big and
um
and i think
what it uh
i mean the reason the argument i make
about why this happened surely at two
million years ago is kind of twofold one
is that everything fits at that point so
that's the point in which you see
smaller mouths smaller teeth evidence of
smaller guts to judge from the shape of
the ribs and the pelvis and by the way
um for the first time a commitment to
sleeping on the ground because uh for
the first time you have a construction
of the of the organism you know the the
human um in a way that is not easy to
climb trees
ah so that made it possible for us to
not have to climb trees that that's the
idea at least in part
yeah and the australopithecines could
climb trees so they surely would have
slept in trees
but humans nowadays you can't imagine
them being able to regularly climb up
into trees and always be able to make a
nest in the way that a chimpanzee or an
australopithecine could
so they'd have to sleep on the ground
often well you have to be nuts to sleep
on the ground if you don't have fire to
protect you
so i think i think that all points to um
to why it makes sense that fire was
first controlled around 2 million years
ago literally about 1.9
and um
the 1.9 million years ago and then the
other reason is that
subsequently to that point
no dramatic events happen in human
evolution which could be consistent with
the acquisition of something so
important as the control of fire
so you know there is no subsequent time
that makes sense in terms of oh yeah
they must have got fire and therefore
therefore what nothing happens
you know you get a steady increase in
brain size you get a variation in tooth
size where generally it's declining but
but
no big things
okay so so we we've we've touched on
autobiographical issues we talked about
your work with google we we touched on
demonic males and the rating and now
we've we've touched on cooking and fire
use so maybe because
i want to get to your third book before
we run out of time too
you you got really really interested in
aggression particularly aggression among
males and it's and it's and the
particular forms it takes in human
beings and our close relatives but then
in your last book the goodness paradox
you really turned your attention to how
that proclivity for extreme aggression
came under some degree of social control
and that's a fascinating issue in and of
itself so maybe maybe we could talk
about that you you distinguish first
between two kinds of aggression
proactive and reactive a classic
distinction so do you want to start
there and then elaborate out the thesis
is that is that a reasonable way of
approaching it yeah it is so yes fox
early so the goodness paradox is the
title of this book and it refers
as a paradox
to the fact that humans are so extreme
with regard to aggression and
non-aggression
so we're extremely aggressive in the
sense that like chimpanzees we have
these demonic tendencies to go off and
kill members of neighboring groups using
our overwhelming power when we can get a
big group attacking a small group and so
on um in a way that uh that
no other species
know the mammals
do
and in a way that horrifies us in
retrospect often and makes us
drop drop our draw drop our jaws at our
own behavioral possibilities
yeah i mean you know they
were still living in the shadow of world
war ii and the holocaust um
and so you know for
so many i mean almost everybody who
writes about human behavior is affected
by that and still thinking about how did
that come to be and how do we avoid it
in the future
so you know there's that that angle on
humans
and but the other angle which makes
human behavior so paradoxical
is that we are the kindest and most
tolerant and most gentle of animals and
people since the ancient greeks have
said well like a domesticated animal
you know we we meet strangers we're so
nice to each other we don't have
automatic aggression we're nothing like
wild animals that we share food
and make that the basis of many of our
social interactions yeah
and so you know for decades well for
centuries uh people have uh tended to
solve this paradox by saying either that
uh we are naturally aggressive and uh we
learn
culturally to be nice to each other or
vice versa
and so you know the famous uh
debate between hobbs and russo as people
uh put it now you know
hobbs takes the the naturally aggressive
perspective and russo takes the
naturally kind perspective and this goes
on i mean there's there's a book
recently published by a dutch historian
called ronald bregman who's called human
kindness saying well actually humans are
spontaneously naturally kind
so
you know it's absurd
in retrospect to think that people are
trying to
to arbitrate between these two views
that one is correct or the other is
correct because they're both right
you know
i think it's very very clear that humans
have got tendencies for appalling
violence which will be elicited under
the appropriate circumstances regardless
of what ethnicity or culture or religion
you come from
and equally it is very clear that people
grow up uh to be spontaneously
thoroughly moral and kind and uh
tolerant with each other
we have these two tendencies and you
mentioned this division between two
types of aggression a proactive and
reactive
it's a division that that as you as a
psychologist said it's a familiar
distinction that's fine but i i will
take credit for bringing it into
biological anthropology because people
thinking about the evolution of human
behavior for some reason did not apply
it
well
the short story is this the way to think
about human aggression and
non-aggression is that we are relatively
elevated for the propensity for
proactive aggression
because all of the war and the holocaust
your stuff you're talking about that's
all proactive
right that's planned that's that's
multi-party that's
organized it's social it's it's one
group against another
yeah and and it follows exactly the
chimpanzee principle of imbalance of
power you only do it if you can get away
with it and feel very comfortable that
you're not going to get hurt in the
process
so you know the the killers of the jews
and the gypsies and the homosexuals uh
and the holocaust
very very rarely got any pushback
they were butchers
and that's the nature of proactive
aggression
so humans are elevated for that in the
sense that we have a very high
propensity to do it if we the
circumstances are right which is right
and part of that circumstance is that
we're defining the the entities upon
which that aggression is afflicted as
outside what constitutes human because
within the human definition all the
standard rules of morality apply and
that's sort of equivalent correct me if
you think i'm making an error here
that's sort of equivalent to the chimp
distinction between the chimps that are
in their own group and the chimps that
are from
another group altogether you're right
and by the way in a shocking addition to
that
if you take the ethnographies of people
living in small-scale societies
including hunters and gatherers and
small-scale farmers
you find the same thing
you find
that within the ethno-linguistic society
in other words the people who speak the
same language we are humans
and the other people are not humans
right right and that's very that's a
very common well and it's i guess it's
also partly because
you can rely on those who are like you
it's almost the definition of them being
like you that they accept your
definitions of right and wrong so that
you can predict their behavior
you can enter into a social contract
with them with implicit understanding
whereas with an outsider
you don't know what rules apply and so
their behavior isn't predictable and and
they don't obviously fall within
the the the overarching definition of
of moral and maybe that's what you know
underlies the definition of human in
some sense for us yeah i mean that seems
like a reasonable explanation but the
net result is that even a total stranger
in a completely weak state
uh the the first thing that uh
that you do you're living in a small
scale society when you encounter such a
person
is not to say here have a cup of tea and
let's find out your morals it's a
killing right right right so uh you know
i say this because there's a romantic
view
that uh among
small-scale
people particularly uh hunters and
gatherers uh there is uh this extension
of
um generosity of spirit
to people of different languages and
you can argue very strongly against that
so let me ask you a question that just
popped into my mind about that i mean
it's a compelling idea i know that in
the uh
in in
i think it's in genesis in the abrahamic
stories
there's tremendous emphasis on the
hospitality that has to be shown to a
stranger
and so
that seems to be an ex
that seems to be an exception to that
general principle
and so
i think it's a definition of the
stranger that's that's the issue you
know to me
what you're talking about would
typically be a stranger who you do not
know personally
but who speaks the same language as you
who's part of you know the larger
series of judaic tribes right right so
still in still encapsulated within the
idea of what constitutes the central
people
right yeah okay okay okay well that
could well be and that i mean and
obviously that's going to be the case
from a historical perspective because
the idea of
everyone who's morphologically similar
being human
that idea obviously must have moved out
from tribe to slightly larger group to
larger groups still and so forth as our
groups got bigger and bigger and
yeah well and maybe we've got some more
all one world
right right right well at least we yeah
we do that to some degree automatic
enemy is is horrendous
right he says you really have to think
yourself back into a very different past
uh to understand this
so that's all proactive aggression the
proactive aggression the the use of uh
of power uh to uh to damage anyone
outside your group and then the reactive
aggression that you describe is also
characteristic of other of many many
other animals who engage in male-to-male
conflict so that's not unique to human
beings and and that's that involves
emotional reactivity it's impulsive it's
immediate
all this defensive that's right it's all
those things so it's what we ordinarily
think of as aggression because so many
people think of proactive aggression as
something that is sort of just cultural
and and just human taught and that sort
of thing and even though there's very
important cultural elements to it it's
part of our biology um but reactive
aggression is what people if you look up
aggression in a textbook animal behavior
it's almost all about reactive
aggression
often exclusively about it so react
aggression is uh testosterone fueled uh
it's it's losing your temper
as you say it's impulsive it's motivated
by anger
not not only by anger but angers
anger frustration
uh shame associated with emotions that's
right
and what's what's striking about humans
uh
is that we are very down regulated for
reactive aggression compared to
our close relatives
so and the way that you can see this
manifest is that the rate at which you
get actual physical aggression happening
in a small-scale society
in humans compared to in a a group of
wild chimpanzees
is two to three orders of magnitude
difference that is to say hundreds to
thousands of times less frequent in
humans than in chimpanzees or in bonobos
too
you know the famously peaceful bonobos
but nevertheless bonobos are not nearly
as peaceful
as humans
so we have when we're way down the scale
of reactive aggression and at the same
time we're way up the scale on on
proactive aggression and the goodness
paradox is a story of how did we get
this astonishing mixture
and i think you know we actually have a
really good story for it now a really
good understanding
and and it uh yeah well some of it in
the book some of it you outlined intense
attempts by people within
human social groups everywhere to
socialize children into controlling
their reactive aggression yeah and i i
know there's literature i interviewed
richard trombley on this youtube channel
i saw the podcast yeah oh okay so you
know we talked about the studies showing
that you know a small percentage of
two-year-olds are spontaneously
aggressive
if you put them in groups of other
two-year-olds it's only about five
percent and virtually all of them are
male and virtually all of them are
socialized out of that by the time
they're four but a small proportion
aren't and they tend to be lifetime
aggressors and those are the ones that
well you have a story about them i think
well i mean i i think that's the the
residue of um a population that would
have been 100 like that uh if you go
back 300 000 years ago you know all our
babies uh would have been uh highly
aggressive and would have retained that
aggressiveness uh throughout life
and the reason we can say that uh is
um
you know there are two main points
first of all our anatomy
uh
compared to our earlier ancestors
looks like the anatomy of a domesticated
animal compared to a wild animal
and what i'm saying our earlier
ancestors i'm thinking very specifically
of what happened around 300 000 years
ago
so this is when we first get the first
glimmerings of our species moving into
sapionization
sapionization the process of becoming
homo sapiens
people now
say it started about 300 000 years ago
that thanks to
fossil discoveries uh in morocco
and that's when you first start getting
smaller teeth
and
smaller mouths
indicative of a trend that will get
increasingly strong
by the time you have homo sapiens as a
recognizable species
you have several of the characteristics
that archaeologists use to mark a
domesticated animal compared to its wild
ancestors
the the four characteristics they use
are
smaller teeth and jaws
reduced differences between males and
females reduced sexual dimorphism
a reduction in body size
and those three things all happen fairly
early in homo sapiens
and then the fourth thing is a reduced
brain size
uh astonishingly uh there is evidence
for reduced brain stars in homo sapiens
compared to
um our earlier phases right but known as
not necessarily any loss of cognitive
power
just like in domesticated animals
there's no evidence of a loss of
cognitive power in domesticated animals
compared to their wild ancestors even
though they have smaller brains and you
i think you posited that that was a
consequence of decreased size of the
brain areas associated with reactive
emotions
that's part of it anyways um
yes you you may be extending slightly
beyond what i said but i actually do
think that that's right
uh it seems to me that
there's quite a bit of evidence that um
part of the contribution to brain size
is associated with reactive aggression
and so you know bonobos are less
reactively aggressive than chimpanzees
they have smaller brains than
chimpanzees females are less reactively
aggressive than males females in a whole
bunch of species have smaller brains
domesticated animals all have smaller
brains than their wild ancestors
and and there's even some very
provocative evidence that um
if you give testosterone to
humans
then um it increases the size of the
brain
even to adult humans
so now you mentioned in in the goodness
paradox some early hypotheses about how
human beings might have become
domesticated because obviously we
domesticated domesticated animals and
there were wild hypotheses like
some sort of super race that had
domesticated us all and then disappeared
and these were very early speculations
but you have a hypothesis about how this
might have come about that doesn't
involve such uh what would you call
extreme speculation
yeah and it comes originally from
christopher boehm uh who was an
anthropologist who went to look at
chimpanzees and he was really struck by
the huge difference between humans and
chimpanzees in the existence of an alpha
male bully
in chimpanzees you have an alpha male
bully who gets what he wants by using
his personal physical power
in humans you don't have that
and
we often talk informally about humans
having alpha males
but it's not an alpha male in the
primate sense because
the human supposed alpha does not
get that status or or achieve what he
wants by using his personal physical
power it's all through coalitions
but in chimps and bonobos and baboons
and every other primate it's not by
coalitions it's by his personal physical
ability to defeat everybody else
now
you sometimes get in humans in
small-scale societies you sometimes get
a man who tries to do that
who tries to
you know kick sand in the face of every
other male and take their wives and take
their resources
make them feel small and thoroughly mean
to them just by being
the bully on the block
and when that happens
there is a consistent solution
because you have to think about
societies in which there's no police
there's no
no one to help you you're just on your
own in your society and here is this guy
who is being incredibly objectionable
and may actually kill other people but
even if he doesn't kill them he's trying
to he's taking their wives he's pushing
them around
so there's various kinds of social uh
responses uh
people can try
pleading with him to behave better they
can laugh in his face they can ostracize
him they can ignore him
they can try and move away and exile him
just by going away but
none of those mechanisms will work in
the face of a really determined
desperate
so in the end
he gets killed
now that's what happens nowadays and
what christians weapons weapons would
have contributed to that too i suspect
because it's it's easier to be a bully
when you're huge and everyone else is
small and they don't have weapons but
once weapons emerge the advantage of
physical strength is decreased
substantially at least in principle
is that
well yeah i mean weapons play a funny
role and it's almost certain that the
kinds of weapons that would be needed
for a bully to use them uh existed long
before 300 000 years ago you know there
are very nicely um preserved spears from
400 000 right yeah i'm thinking more
about weapons used against the bully
well yes
um
but uh
you know animals uh without weapons can
kill
others
quite safely even nowadays you have
descriptions of of humans killing
without weapons
so how much weapons you really mattered
is unclear you can kind of argue it both
ways
but but either way
um
the uh
what you see in the present
is the argument that is taken back into
the past
and i like this argument a lot because
i think it is a really tidy explanation
for the fact that
beginning around 300 000 years ago
we
had this reduction in reactive
aggression and there is no other
explanation other than
a communal effort at executing that can
account for the removal of
this would-be desperate this bully who
uses his physical strength
that's why
no other primate has escaped having an
alpha male bully
only humans
have converted an alpha male bully into
an alliance of males
among whom
there is a sort of formal level of
equality
and if anybody in that alliance tries to
throw their weight around they know what
will happen
they will get taken out as
as the bully originally did right so you
you paused in in the goodness paradox
that there's been enough of that in
human societies over the last
very long period of time
have markedly decreased the propensity
for reactive aggression to such a degree
that it's also transformed our
morphology and our and our psychology
absolutely at the biological level right
right and you know it probably
accelerated over time uh the the loss of
reactive aggression uh the move towards
this domestication-like species that we
are now
um
people
sometimes want to suggest that other
forces like female choice would have
come in females choosing to mate with
the kinder gentler more domesticated
male
the problem with that is that as long as
you had a bully who was capable of
exerting his physical force it wouldn't
matter if a female was exerting female
choice
you know she would come along and say i
don't want to mate with you and he would
say too bad
and
punch her chosen male in the face and
grant take her off
and make with her and rape her
and you know it's it's a brutal vision
but uh this seems to me to conform
to what we know about primates and to be
the only explanation for how humans
escaped what other primates have in
terms of alpha males
and
there is an obvious
reason for what it was that enabled
humans to make that escape
and that is language
because what language enabled the
the beta males
the coalition of the subordinated males
to do is to make a plan
and now all of a sudden they could
convert their individual tendencies for
proactive aggression which are not
enough
into an alliance
and of course it's very difficult you
know it's not just simple language
because they've got to be able to
work out
how to approach someone suggest this
idea you know to float the possibility
of killing
the offender
without themselves being exposed to the
possibility of being shocked to the
offender and themselves being killed
so it's a complicated business and i say
that to emphasize that
other species of humans like
neanderthals
probably had pretty good language
themselves
but i think the ancestors of sapiens
must have been the ones
whose linguistic ability for whatever
reason got to the point of being so
sophisticated that they could dare
develop the sort of plan
that would enable them consistently
to get rid of
the supreme bullies
there there was a movie i unfortunately
don't remember its name but it was
released in the 1980s and maybe one of
the viewers of this can supply us with
the name
it documented the lives of a very of
villagers a very isolated and
archaic japanese village and there was a
group of villagers a family of villagers
in there that consistently broke the
rules and pilfered food
and all of the villagers
conspired together as a consequence of
that
and
in the night
crept into their house and killed all of
them
it's exactly the scenario you describe
it's an unbelievably striking movie um i
saw it in a repertory theater i really
like to know
uh
i'd really like to know the name of it
at the end of it two
men carry their aged
parents off to a mountain to abandon
them which is the typical way of dealing
with elders in this particular village
and one woman goes voluntarily and the
other fights and struggles and it's a
horrific scene so that's another part of
the movie but
i would like to find
it
given this conversation because it its
exact representation of the process that
you described it's the only thing i've
ever seen like that yeah i mean i hadn't
heard of that movie but but i can cite
you a number of
you know cases nowadays even in texas
where similar sorts of things happen
where you get isolated communities uh
where the police are inadequate and and
people just take it on themselves
but the case you mentioned is not quite
like the one i was mentioning because it
involves uh people being punished for
pilfering food
but it it yeah it's not that's right
it's it's more it's breaking it's
breaking the moral code it should be a
variant of that yes
and i think you know it's very
significant what you just said
because
i think that once you have the ability
to safely execute using
the absolute power of an alliance
against a victim you also have
the ability
to control
society through social norms so do you
do you think
is what you're claiming
the transformation of proactive
aggression
into use within the group to control
reactive aggression within the group so
is what is what happens that the
conspiratorial parties
define
the bully
as a consequence of his behavior as
non-human
and are then able to use their intrinsic
proclivity for proactive aggression to
target him
yeah yeah i mean whether they define it
as non-human that's uh you know yeah i'm
just wondering if he fits it if he
starts to slip into that category
because that category obviously exists
in some sense because it enables these
acts of proactive aggression to take
place
right there has to be some psychological
mechanism that
is
sufficiently profound to allow the
perception of a morphologically human
being as not human so that you can
attack them without
you know without violating your moral
code well i have seen
some accounts which are
that they say it's time to send
bert
whoever back to the witches because he
looks like a witch right right right
right right and you talk about witches
and sorcery to some degree in your book
too and and
and and
that's also a topic of gossip
mm-hmm right so there will be
psychological mechanisms that allow
people to justify to themselves but what
they're basically doing is making
themselves safe from you know someone
who is a tyrant
and
but but my you know i really want to
come back to this point that i think
there are two processes that go on once
humans have this ability to kill in this
predictable safe way
and the first is
the loss of the alpha male and therefore
the loss of alpha male genes and
therefore the loss of reactive
aggression and therefore the
self-domestication that
actually ends up defining our species in
terms of our morphology as well as our
behavior
we are the domesticated version of
the species that lived 300 000 years ago
but the other process that happens is
that because
this group of males who have now
acquired the power of life and death
over
an alpha male they have acquired the
power of life and death over everybody
in the group
so they are
the supreme
dictators
as a group
of what is okay
they now
therefore have created a world in which
they can specify what is good and what
is bad what is right and what is wrong
they have created a moral system
and from then on
i think you see an intensification of
the degree to which males
are
ruling the society
very often the rules that they impose
will be good for everybody
such as
there shall be no murder
except when we say it's a good thing
but sometimes the rules will not be good
for everyone's society such as
when we tell females that we want them
to have sex with a stranger then they're
done we're gonna do it
or
if the bachelors will not be allowed
anywhere near the women or our choice
pieces of food in other words there are
selfish aspects to
the
male what does it become now something
like a patriarchy
which
go alongside the aspects that are good
for the group as a whole
and and i i think that this is a
a concept that is useful for thinking
about the origins of
of many of the major political
institutions or the major social
institutions
and the obvious ones are
the system of justice
the system of religion
the systems of politics the systems of
law
ultimately going back to
alliances among males who have agreed
among themselves
not to have any kind of alpha male
and who then have the power
that they can impose throughout society
that is a really good place to bring
this discussion to a close we covered
a tremendous amount of material today in
the last 90 minutes or so and touched on
the three year three books
um i'm going to repeat their titles for
everyone so that
people who are interested can read them
which i would highly recommend
maybe i'll let you do that because i've
lost my notes here i want to get the
titles right so the first one was
demonic males demonic males apes on the
origins of human violence
1996 yeah and then catching fire
catching fire how cooking made us human
2009
and then the goodness paradox
that relates strange relationship
between violence and virtue in human
evolution published in 2019
well thank you very much for talking to
me today and for walking walking all me
through that and and and the audience
that i
have no doubt will appreciate this
through it as well and there's lots of
other things i would have liked to have
talked to you about and that really flew
by as far as i was concerned so i hope
everyone else feels that way as well and
um maybe we can get a chance to talk
through some of these things i'd be
interested in hearing more from you
about
your ideas about how more complex
political structures might have emerged
from this initial
uh
say consensus against violence something
like that yeah that's that's a very
interesting development
developmental historical idea i suppose
so anything else you'd like to add to to
close things off or
do you want to have another hour and a
half
yeah well that would be nice and we'll
do it again i'd like to do that again
maybe we can talk together with franz
dewal if i can convince him to do that
that might be fun
yeah right
all right well thank you very much
thank you so much
my pleasure it was it was and and thanks
again for agreeing to do this it was a
pleasure talking to you pleasure meeting
you and thank you for for your books
i've learned a tremendous amount reading
them and enjoyed it very much too uh
so
till we meet again
okay all right all right bye bye
[Music]
you